jetzt ist der hacker hätten was geht
leute hier ist euer essen johnson der
erste und heute habe ich etwas ganz
besonders für euch ausgedacht und zwar
befinden wir uns hier in gun game das
ist eine neue lobby leute und zwar
wollte ich eigentlich gerade für euch
ein tutorial aufnehmen wie man ganz
leicht dazu nach full die rüstung kommt
von uncharted und ein scharfes schwert
aber ich sehe gerade die haben die map
geänderten gun game und deswegen machen
wir das jetzt einfach unvorbereitet
spontan und ich versuche euch bisschen
so ja einfach mal zu zeigen wie ich das
mache zwar so macht man das gar nicht
auf gar keinen fall wenn man jung ist
lara gut gebracht und zwar klar so
basics wie es treffen sind auch hier
nützlich kommt tritt frist
so erwischte um im wesentlichen muss
halt einfach aufpassen und darauf achten
dass man auf die leute gerade wenig
leben haben der hier ist der krieg
fliegt die leute die ihn so hart am heck
er ihnen ganz ehrlich diese leute sind
hier so hart am hacken des körpers
können locker van hecke report seit ich
müsste einfach gar nichts machen ich
möchte einfach nur reingehen und werden
allein diese folge ist wahrscheinlich
ein fünffacher hacker report ganz
ehrlich guckt euch mal um ok level 9
sagt ja immer versuchen die gegner ins
wasser zu schlagen das ist schon mal ein
guter anfang
gerade wenn ihr am anfang nur die holz
habt ok haben uns jetzt ein bisschen
hochgearbeitet okay ja und wie die auch
über hecken ist frisst die scheiße guckt
euch doch mal
es gibt es nicht ohne ich hab' ich
glaube ich hab gerade mit dem satz zum
hacker report nicht zu viel versprochen
so ok egal wir probieren das 14
lol alter dennoch
wieder geflogen ist
neue gut manchmal fallen menschen auch
einfach auf seerose oder fall einfach
ins wasser
da muss man mit klarkommen wichtig ist
dass man kühlen kopf bewahrt und sich
halt möglichst weit weg von
irgendwelchen unübersehbaren wasser
durch anhält und niemals über wasser zu
den gegner springt das ganze ist ja auch
hecken oder aus bei dem der du schön am
hacken alles klar
schlägt mich über den rücken ok wenn die
mama woanders finden
ok wenn ihr verfolgt okay gut vielleicht
gebe ich auch einfach gleich direkt im
heads-up egal
schaue man gleich mal hier geht es am
team ganz schön auf den schwächeren
gehen weg mit ihr soll mit der
richtlinie und ich weiß nicht wie ich
meine online wie schlimm es tut mir so
leid dass ich unsichtbar wie nun ein
läufer draufgehen ein herz hallo legal
komm her kommen so sagt er
jetzt geht's richtig rund zehn laibe wir
sind zweistellig 11 level sehr gut also
einfach geschält ich würd mal einfach
empfehlen man hier raus zu gehen an
diese stelle
früher hab ich halt immer auf der
anderen web habe ich immer in einer von
hinten
ich weiß auch nicht wo der jetzt gerade
er kam aber egal fröhlich hat immer
richtung ist okay manchmal auch menschen
unsichtbar
dann solltet ihr euch von den fernhalten
ganz einfache sache denn unsichtbar
heute sind einfach schwerer zu können
hier kann man schon mal ganz gut im
griff kids for names gefühl ja kommt den
hunger
okay da oben kämpft ja schön auf gehwege
mir über alles la vida die elf level ich
würde einfach mal diesen platz hier
empfehlen dann gerne mal etwas hat man
einfach mal so rein drehen wir das kennt
vom streifen sowie sind schon beim gold
wert ist eigentlich ein bisschen der
turning point dann geht es prinzipiell
prinzipien spelling tendenziell aufwärts
dem leben so kommen ich habe auch noch
dankeschön so ok gut das haben jetzt ein
bischof aus dem konzept gebracht hätte
ich das diese anderen gäste hatte ich
könnte jetzt schön mein ding machen
meiner alt bekannten trick da bin ich
schon auf level 144 gekommen so auf der
alb map das geht natürlich nicht ich
weiß nicht was dauerhaft geändert wurde
oder ob jetzt einfach nur hier momentan
diese änderung erleben und die alte map
wieder zurück kommt oder ob man das über
wollten kann der biss der gerade
verschwunden oder sms wasser gesprungen
aber es hat tatsächlich geklappt hat ihn
gesehen
lol lol lol
wie hat er fit ist und court
alter schwede ich hab mich ob wir das
gesehen für hitzige bieten habe ich bin
kein schaden gemacht dass er die box
rüstung protokoll muss man da muss man
dazu noch irgendwas sagen schaut euch
einfach alle wie die leute mich hier
treffen
es ist nicht normal das kann mir keiner
erzählen dass das normal ist okay derart
fläche grabmal keine hacks an die man ja
genommen worden
ok egal wer sammelt hat unser leben
verloren richtig darum gegangen egal dem
hosting sagte hammer guckt euch das noch
mal anders ist so bitter das ist so hat
bitte alle ja danke genauen okay gut da
wie 3 wieder ein bisschen zu hacken
gerade eben ja und geht es wieder ab 1
dann geht es wieder ab schreibt mal und
in die kommentare ich bin auch mal
gespannt wie viele hacker in der folge
gesehen
ich glaube alle jederzeit zwischen 100
und wieder hat mich gewöhnlich umgelegt
willkommen im hacker paradies älter was
ist das ursprünglich sollte das ein
tutorial werden immer schön auf den
russen bekommen
jetzt wird ein quadruple triple
quintuple hacker report wo wir doch die
wärme die clean up gene einfach noch
nicht so wirklich brennpunkt die gold
axt haben wir ja da muss einfach auf
einen drauf gehen
das ist das was ich so ein bisschen
realisiert habe dass bringt einfach
nichts da irgendwie auch möglich viele
man muss einfach einen raussuchen weil
dann kommt wohl als ob er darüber
gewusst mit einem herz der kommt von dem
so hartwig gnädiger und ich mit ihnen
kind habe ich gut das klappt das war
knapp und hab ich hab's gesehen ich bin
einfach gezielt nur auf den einer raus
gegangen einfach nur noch ein herz hatte
das ist ein bisschen meine strategie
einfach wirklich sind quasi immer
irgendwelche an ballungen da und 450
lang auf einer 1
leute wie einfach echt immer auf den
seerose die haben alle ordentliche
portion zielwasser getrunken so die
leute ja okay wir sind schon ein
bisschen im gold wissen schon im gold
modus stellt man sollte halt aufpassen
dass man gerade wenn man ein bisschen
höheres level hat sich halt von stellen
weg hält wo man einfach sinnlos ins
wasser gerichtet wird wo man einfach
nichts machen kann
hauptsächlich diese schmalen brücken da
der der ist einfach geil
der hat aber szenisch zu seiner ex an
dem geht's gut dabei jetzt kommts mir
geh weg geh weg danke geweckt wie der
htm haqqani style was ist das ich kann
den nicht treffen
wie er trainiert jetzt wieder rund ok ja
cool ich versuche mir drin bist
abstauben hat nicht funktioniert
der hegau jedoch nicht auf mich drauf
einfach nicht alles was ich im leben
will ist einfach nicht von einem hacker
verfolgt zu werden
es ist zu viel verlangt so zwang italien
pakets geholt egal
red hat er sich ingo legal und sicher
war sehr schön und jetzt die goldex okay
es sind schon ein paar sehr sehr kuriose
dabei muss man sagen ach übrigens leute
was ich auch noch ansprechen wollte dazu
kommt auch demnächst wenn man eigenes
video
ich werde bei diesem mcdonald's contest
mitmachen von dem vielleicht schon
gehört hat aber nicht so oft präsent
basis achim killer bücher bekommen des
westens gewesen sondern einfach weil ich
bock ab und ich werde so ein das kann
ich jetzt schon mal sagen einen mac es
raus bringen
dazu wird es wie gesagt ein eigenes
video nochmal geben ich glaube ich bin
ein bisschen unsichtbar für manche aber
egal dafür hätten mich manchmal auch
bisschen aus der welt raus zwingen
fast alles am ende gleicht sich das
alles auf so level 17
weiter geht es ja wie gesagt den hab ich
hab mir gestern schon mal erstes
konzepte oder zu überlegt war schon so
weit das rohgold jetzt umso auffälliger
war schon quasi so weit dass gestern
abend schon raus zu holen hat alba hat
das macht jetzt nicht so nur 15 west
gibt es ein bisschen mehr zeit und lässt
dir selbst bisschen mehr zeit und macht
das dann gut so mitgestalten bild
aussuchen kann er viel machen aber kann
es auch schon kann es schnell dahin
gleiches bewerbung und damit ich will
hat das ordentlich macht und jetzt jetzt
jetzt kriegt man langsam unsere level
hier zusammen ein bisschen hoch halt
immer pakets mitnehmen so bisschen
rumlaufen und weghalten von dem hacker
seien und fern halten von dem wir nicht
wer kein tenor gottwald euch auf der
durch den westen zu schlagen ist ja
genau dann einfach mal draufhalten wohl
nur noch wenige herzen da sind dann
läuft das auch seht ihr auf jeden fall
jetzt ist der erste direkt gewählte weg
weg weg weg weg
ob er weiß dass ich aufnehme
wahrscheinlich nicht auf weil das doch
vielleicht hat er es geahnt
das ist halt so wert angst vorm
schwarzen mann nur dass er das der typ
ist der mann die schwarze sondern am
hacken
ja komm runter
sicherheit durch zieht einfach auf denen
der schon geschwächt ist
dann habt ihr weniger probleme wenn er
gerade wenn er in zweier- dreier-
vierer- fünferteam ist was ja durchaus
mal passieren soll tut euch selbst
eingefallen und geht einfach auf den
einen nur auf den einen den man einfach
angegriffen jetzt auf denen hier und
zwar bis der down ist setzen wir schon
relativ weit von leni aber jetzt über
dieses wasserlöcher sich einfach nicht
hin so ok 41 level läuft alles soweit
wir haben jetzt krass ich wollte ich
wollte eigentlich level wird fulda in
zehn minuten hatte ich mir als ziel
gesetzt auf der alten map aber jetzt
immer auf den neuen web und ab nachdem
es anfangs ist anfällig bisschen schwer
getan haben stehen wir jetzt endlich
doch ganz gut da oder konnte er ist es
dass der heckengäu ich weiß es nicht und
ich würde es nicht riskieren ich wissen
ich gar nicht wissen hierüber ja das ist
was ist da war nicht nennen
du bleibst mal schön da drüben mach du
mal da drüben dann legen und ich mir
seitlich in kiel mit so und dann hier
noch in kiel mit und inzwischen auf
level 45 mal echt aufpassen dass wenn
ich ins wasser fallen weil das war krass
bitter jetzt schon so weit gekommen
und wo sind die gegner jetzt kann man ja
schon fast hätte und nicht ins wasser
nicht ins wasser das wasser ihr größter
feind war okay er komme das kein ding
condor.com richtig viel raus hier raus
und hat die politik ist schon hart jetzt
muss den herrischen art problem
marquardt verpackt und eltern ein
jetzt wird man halt so hart level
ok dann aber den hergeholt ist alles
kein problem wir können und wir können
wieder zurückschaffen dass er einfach
jetzt einfach spontan aufgenommen wie
der struggle so ist so ne flüchtete
hinten 35 aber alles in ordnung sind mit
dem patentierten eisenstadt da schiebt
er hat sich der mädchen gerettet
da kommen ein paar leute gehen halt
natürlich auch was man auch sehr gut
verstehen kann einfach auf den der das
beste klub hat ist auch logisch so
erweitert jetzt sind wir relativ gut
zurückgekommen habe ich gefühl am montag
ins mitgefangen den geholt sagt zack
zack bis zum direkten gegner umtänzeln
ist sowieso eine ganz knappe methode wie
man scheint den erwischen den erwischen
wenn halt so viel da sie dann wirklich
nur auf einen einzelnen gehen ok ich
hier sehe ich völlig auch selbst aber so
richtig hat die orientierung bei monate
alter schweres keine schlechte position
den haben wir geholt 746 und wir nähern
uns mit beachtlicher geschwindigkeit der
fuldaer rüstung fohlen startet mit
sharpless die erschwert wenn uns jetzt
nicht nur einer ins wasser schlägt sagt
bahr
wo man natürlich nicht da kommt jetzt
wieder darunter
homoki jetzt ein bisschen abgreifen
sagte geholt und hinke geholt soll dann
aber auch ich muss erstmal diese
klickerei macht ist so hart anstrengend
leute das ist so stick anstrengt egal
passt alles kommt sagt barbara sowie bei
dem aus nicht so gut
okay das hat und auch morgen hat
irgendwann wenn man das problem ist dass
die erschwert schon krass gucken ja sehr
schön also man kann hier übrigens gut
warten
man hat halt dann immer ein bisschen
mehr gegner aber es geht also das ist
gar kein schlechter ort hier einfach
hier unten also wie so ein bisschen
rumlaufen und das equipment fahren und
wenn man dann das gut equipment hat dann
kann man auch rausgehen und jetzt sind
wir halt so weit und ihr habt ihr seht
wie es müssten jetzt fuldaer sein
es sind wir glaube ich nicht ganz
oh gott zwei jahren zwei jahren 2002
herzen aber jetzt soweit die zweite
sinnvoll ihr protection enchanted und
müssen das jetzt nur noch halten wir
verstecken uns kurz hier oben sicherlich
ist man sie mit dem kopf steckt okay der
soll auch nicht ob ich weiß nicht ist er
am hacken das noch 1990
von bergen gegen malta okay ganz
geschafft heute das ging relativ schnell
und nein nein nein die sind halt alle
ein herz bei dem der typen und laufen
und laufen alle auf mich drauf ist ist
verständlich es verständlich ist
vollkommen verständlich und ich muss
jetzt aber zu sehen dass wir jetzt hier
hoch kommen und wir sind safe leute habt
es gesehen gut es war jetzt bisschen
mehr ich werde es für euch zusammen
karten auf der neuen map aber das ist so
bis in meine taktik ich hoffe ihr konnte
da irgendwas sehen durchziehen auf die
leute die wenig herzen haben nicht
unbedingt zu den stellen laufen wo so
viel wasser ist bisschen kalkulieren wie
drehe ich mich reine milch ins wasser
geschlagen werden kann dass meine
persönlichen tipps falls ihr garnier
spielt versucht die gerne mal anzuwenden
wir sind zwar nicht so wie du wieder
drin macht's gut und